Wells Adams we're winding down on
paradise and yet the dumpster fire still
seems like it's really oblate it never
goes out the eternal flame it's the
eternal flame of a dumpster fire I love
that so what we have just seen on Monday
night's episode is Dean appearing to
possibly be about to break up with
Caitlyn yeah he's living up to that
mustache I feel like represented growth
like he literally grew the mustache I
grew up but now I'm feeling different no
I think the mustache represents
creepiness and that's what's happening
he is like turning back to like his old
ways I don't know man I love Dean so
much but like yeah he's falling back
into like old Dean stuff I feel like
that's the vibe that a lot of people in
bachelor nation have with Dean perhaps
even including myself which is I love
him meat he kind of does some not cool
things somehow he like is charming
enough to get away with some of the more
than some people might be able to I know
when he was like I'd be a terrible
boyfriend and she laughs to in any other
world people be like oh this is a very
big red flag
he told Kalyn I don't really want to be
in a relationship it's a convinced me
otherwise situation and I was sort of
yelling at my TV Kalyn tell him you
don't want to convince him otherwise why
do you think she didn't speak up more in
that moment I mean I think that she
falls into the thing that everyone falls
into a Dean is like this you just get
like the heart emoji eyes you know like
you just kind of like lost in that
mustache and those baby blues I don't I
don't get it like there is I will say
like there is something about him that
is very intriguing like and I said it's
a bunch like the apartment that wishes I
could be like Dean like a guy that would
just like I'm gonna travel the world and
like have this like lays a fair attitude
about everything like and like probably
not pay taxes you know like all this
stuff but like there's a part of me
that's like I can't do that because I
need like stability and stuff there's
there's a thing that I wish I I wish I
was more like that yeah and I think a
lot of women see that in that's cool
like he travels around the world
yeah he you know it's like right now
he's a yacht week and the Croatia you
know like yeah I want to do that too
it's romantic
yeah so I get it and then I also like
that whole scene of like Demi and I
talking to her is like dude you know
what
happen right like I wanted to ask you
about that because I mean we have not
seen Dean make halen any big promises
have seen him turned down other dates
yes he seems to be being sweet to her so
what made you say to Kailyn hey don't
trust this like did you believe that
Dean had changed or now I think I hoped
he had but there's also just so much
precedent with Dean you know like it's
just it's it's almost like proved me
wrong otherwise Dean and you will see if
he does it or not this seems like Dean
breaks up with Kalyn on her birthday
that's what it seems like he's got a bad
track record when it comes to birthdays
at Paradise I don't know if you remember
I guess it was a couple years ago when
he gave DLO Lombardi that's okay yeah
didn't go well
no well and I guess were we not seeing
some stuff on camera like was Dean
really committing to Kalyan why did she
seem to think it was so serious and that
ya know and then when she talked to him
he seemed to be on a completely
different page was he leading her on I
don't know I mean he does that thing
like he messes with her right like every
time someone pulls him aside and she's
like he's definitely gonna be going on a
date and he comes back he's like hey we
got a talking I'm just kidding I'm gonna
stay here so I feel like he's constantly
keeping her on her toes which isn't
making her not feel very confident in
their relationship yeah and then of
course everyone's like it's Dean you
know what's going to happen you know
octa Dean about this I mean you're there
in paradise here you're telling Kalyn to
call him out have you talked to him
outside of the confines of the show and
been like dude what's up but here's the
thing he's very self-aware of like what
he is I know and and I think you know
like there's this thing that happens
after the show where you go and you tell
everyone what you said behind their back
or bail in an interview because you know
we're all friends and stuff and I and I
think I was like dude I'm sorry I
roasted you they haven't shown any of it
but like I roasted you being like mrs.
bad decision to go with Dean you know
and he's like yeah that's that's
probably a good thing to say about me
you know like he knows that like he's so
do you think Dean has grown and changed
I actually do think he's grown and
changed but you gotta wait and see I got
okay we gotta wait and see all right
I've got a really waiting several a bit
of a longer wait okay all in all the
things he said to Kaelyn what's your
reaction watching that yeah like I think
I'm with you where I wish Kaelyn was
like wait what did you say okay we need
to step back a second I mean but you
know I think she's just kind of like I
said she's just like lost in those baby
blues and I get it like he's a really
charming guy well there's been a lot of
discussion over who is the for lack of a
better term bigger F boy Dean or Blake
yeah good question I mean are we talking
Dean like circa 2017 Dean in the prime
vs. Blake now
oh they're neck-and-neck right now yeah
they're coming around turn three who
knows who's gonna end up with a mattress
I had Demi Burnett in here last week and
she said we kind of need to forgive
Blake and move on now yeah I think it's
it's time is it time I think so Blake
has grown and changed since the show how
do you expect watching all this has
affected him I don't know if you've
talked to him at all I have it and
because I know he's going through a lot
and so and I'm not I'm friendly with him
but I don't know if I'm close enough to
be like let me give you advice on things
I just do that you only do that exactly
but I do I do feel like it's time for
all of us to be like all right and he
said it right on the show he's like I
didn't kill anybody I didn't Rob anybody
your thing is you're not a murderer yeah
I was already I didn't tell anybody here
but I think he's really like what he did
was bad but it was in the grand scheme
of things like not the worst thing like
effectively it was a single guy who
probably made some bad decisions maybe
was over-served and hooked up with two
women back-to-back nights which is not
like the optics of it aren't that great
but like there are much worse things in
the world and and I think that he has
now atoned for those sins okay well he
also did that thing where he released
some text messages between her and Caleb
then he did that and then he's in
trouble again yeah he just makes bad
decision
wow this is so I'm almost having deja vu
I feel like you and I had this
conversation about D yeah
so what does Blake need to do from here
of course we will get the Paradise
reunion special yeah
how does he need to come into that I
think he needs to be really contrite I
think he needs to own what he did I
don't think that's saying like I told
you so do you saw the you know the
receipts is a good play for him I think
he needs to be like listen guys I made a
lot of bad decisions should he have
released the text message no he should
not have that was I don't know who told
him to do that but that was a really bad
friend why do you say that because like
I know how it all plays out right and he
was like a episode away from it being
over you know he was being out of the
woods yeah like it's not his story
anymore you know and like and also like
on the show people are forgiving him and
stuff and I were just kind of over it
he was right there's I'm the precipice
of like just not being a focal point
anymore and then he did that and it was
just like right back in the spotlight of
being a guy who just makes bad decisions
when it comes to the show and with women
so definitely petered out but we did
still see some stuff between Blake and
Kaitlyn and Christina and I was sort of
fascinated watching this conversation
between Christina and Blake where she's
just kind of straight up telling him
what to do yes she seems to have some
kind of power over him I'm like does she
know something that happened at
stagecoach that we do yeah about yet
like tell me about that relationship and
about Christina this season in Paradise
well it's like I don't see a lotta SS so
I'm watching it for the first time with
you guys like I don't know what they're
like personal conversations are like I
find it interesting because a lot of the
heartache that Blake had to go through
was because Christina basically got him
to go on that date in the beginning and
then just like drag him over the coals
with her or which date like right when
Christina got there
she was like yeah we need to go on a
date or whatever and and he that was I
think his actually his worst decision on
the show was going on that date because
he already knew how he felt about her
you know so he should have been like
nomina stick stay back and like figure
things out with taste share figure
things out with Hanna G and like also I
want you to find your thing and like we
know that I'm not the thing so like
go find your thing and thank you but no
thank you but him doing that I think
that's him trying to be the nice guy
thing and I think he should have just
not done that but that date was weird
because he actually like kind of gets
defensive and it's like I can't believe
you're doing this to me and so watching
this back now or she's like just she's
basically like give me that rolls thing
like I'm your only friend here yeah and
there's no like three days ago you like
took me on this date I'd like roast me
look what are you talking on your only
friend so that was interesting to me but
I do think she has I think she has some
power over him and I also think that
like I don't really know about reading
between the lines that Blake wasn't
super into Kaitlyn like maybe wasn't
like really into it so he's like okay so
how is my like way out of this is that
like I continue to do anything the
friendship thing with Christina now I
have to kind of deal with the Kaitlyn
thing and then who knows maybe someone
I'm really into comes down next week and
then Christina will be totally
understanding of me going after her and
won't be as weird with Kaitlyn still
being here and someone new coming I'm
interested in so I think that's where
he's his head's at but then again I'm
just a bartender and no way of knowing
if any that's true well that's a really
fascinating point about that being his
worst mistake was going on that date
with Christina yeah I also want to ask
you about the John Paul Jones Derek pet
fight which we know happens at the
wedding with Chris and Krystal yeah it
seems like John Paul Jones becomes a
different person and then they also
fight on the beach too right so you saw
some of it yeah I was involved in some
of it I guess I don't know if that'll be
shown okay yeah he gets unhinged a
little bit right like and it doesn't
take long for him to get unhinged what I
thought about all that was that's a
messed up place to have a fight it had
someone else's wedding like no the room
and like don't do it at a wedding you
know like that I that I think was what I
liked least about it what bugged me
about that fight was there's not a whole
lot of evidence to confirm what John
Paul saying about Derek he's doing
saying that Derek is a guy who just
hooks up with girls and that he's not a
good yeah he doesn't respect women and
we saw an incredibly respectful Derek
with Demi just episodes ago so it's very
yeah that's what left-field that's what
I said I was like it doesn't make any
sense to me like so Derek's track record
as he went on the he was on the show
with me and he got dumped by Jojo and
then he went on bachelor in paradise for
got engaged and then in fact we got
dumped again and then now he comes on
this one and he gets it I don't know how
he's a terrible dater
another womanizer what would you say to
John Paul Jones saying he doesn't
respect women and he's just hooking up
with women well and that's it and that's
what I think sucks for John Paul Jones
cuz he's doesn't able to see like
Derek's like extremely respectful
conversations with Demi but even you're
friends with Derek like is that the
Derek that you know that one that John
Paul Jones is talking no it doesn't make
any sense and I think I said I was like
your there's no there's no evidence to
back up what you're saying yeah and
that's when you're like okay here is
this are you just coming unglued to come
unglued that continues on like through
the season so I don't want to say too
much about it but yeah that was a very
interesting like play I thought well
it's making me wonder because there's
been this rallying cry for Derek to be
the bachelor yeah I don't know if I'm
okay I would I think it's there yeah and
there might I don't know if there will
be a tide of turn a turning tide on it
at all after all this but I do want to
ask you about the bachelor thing because
obviously the people everybody are talk
is talking about our Derek Mike Peter
Webber I think Tyler Cameron's boot-up
indeed he's out go for him I want to ask
you about Mike because I think everybody
would be super excited to see the first
african-american bachelor but it's
interesting to look at Mike because he's
in a similar situation of Colton
Underwood he came off Bachelorette he
was on paradise and it's like could he
be the bachelor yeah what do you think
about how Mike handled paradise and will
this potentially put him in a place to
be bachelor I mean I don't really know
and I'm not in like those meetings I
think that but you're rooting for Derek
you're not rooting for Mike so that's
interesting right well I'm looking for
Derek because like can the kick gets a
break yeah that's kind of my thought on
it and I also like I thought the way
that he handled that
was I say this honestly I don't know if
there's anyone from bachelor nation that
would have been able to do what he did
as well as he did
we're all selfish beings and if we're
getting hurt like I think that we'd
inevitably get angry and Derek had the
wherewithal to like step back and be
like whoa
okay hold on I got it this is big and I
need to handle this
with kid gloves and I so I thought I was
like man if that's not like Bachelor
stuff then I don't know what is
and he's like 32 and like got a normal
job like he's like I think he's a good
for Mike I don't really know I think he
would be a great bachelor he's got like
a million watt smile he's tall at a
house like he's 31 he's got a job
totally and and he's like a I think he's
a that you know like her he was an
engine yeah so like nothing but of mad
respect for him I think that what people
fail to grasp is you have to build a
shell around that person and I don't
know if he's ready for it just in terms
of the spotlight being on him that much
and no reason I say that because when
you watch back he's just not on the show
a lot I was we haven't seen it much on
Paradise this season I mean Colton we
saw crying everything it's not exactly
and so so that made me wonder I mean
when you're sitting there on the beach
like he just not um in the plot and in
the drama a lot and that is the question
mark that's been raised in my mind when
I'm thinking about producing a
television show yeah and so and I think
that's what people when you hear like
the producers are leaning towards one or
the other like they'd be a good lead or
whatever I think that's what they're
saying is you have to remember yes
everyone deserves love and everyone it
would be so great if everyone could do
it on this nationally televised show but
who's gonna be able to like handle all
of the pricks it's not just dating
people if there's a lot of pressures
that go on around it and I wonder if
they're like he's great but he's not
ready for that quite yet where do you
fall in Peter Webber pilot Pete I don't
know the guy I don't know I mean it
seems like a nice guy he's a pilot
that's cool this would be so many if
he's the bachelor so many like flying
around dates you know yes true I don't
make that kind of money to make those
decisions and here's the here's the
thing they've been really good like at
choosing who the leads are so
for the most like I can root for my
friend as much as I want but like they
know what they're doing like like Hanna
Panna and hey we're both phenomenal like
in homeruns
yeah so like they know a lot more than I
do so I trust them I think that I'm sure
Peter anyone would be great
[Music]